ist unser universum mit einem
paralleluniversum zusammenstoßen
forscher haben einen besonders kalten
fleck in der hintergrundstrahlung
untersucht und festgestellt dass
bisherige erklärung das phänomen nicht
erklären können aber was verursacht den
zweck ihre these der zusammenstoß mit
einem paralleluniversum wie die
wissenschaftler auf diese idee gekommen
den letzten klick zum zweiten wechsel
herzlich willkommen
wenn wir ins weltall blicken dann den
wir nicht nur galaxien sterne gaswolken
und so weiter in großer entfernung wir
sehen auch in die vergangenheit der
grund nicht braucht zeit um zu uns aus
großen entfernungen zum lang wird das
sonnenlicht bei uns zum beispiel rund
acht minuten als wir sehen also die
sonne in einem zustand der acht minuten
alt ist ist eine galaxie zum beispiel 50
lichtjahre entfernt dann sehen wir immer
den zustand von vor 50 jahren ja und so
weiter so können wir fast bis zur
entstehung des universums zurück in die
zeit sehen würde er plätze für eine
galaxie entdeckt die wir in einem
zustand kurz nach dem urknall sehen sie
ist nur 400 millionen jahre nach dem
urknall entstanden und seit vier
milliarden jahre als bmw delphi galaxie
so weit weg 13,4 milliarden lichtjahre
und gesehen wie eben auch zu diesem
zeitpunkt war das nicht so lange zu uns
braucht aber wir können noch weiter in
die vergangenheit gucken
der grund ist die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung sie ist das
überbleibsel eines ereignisses lediglich
ein paar hunderttausend jahre nach dem
urknall die sogenannte rekombination
damals bildeten protonen und elektronen
den wasserstoff das weltall wurde durch
wichtig und photonen lichtteilchen
wurden freigegeben in jedem
kubikzentimeter weltalls gibt es die
überreste dieses ereignisses sind rund
400 vertreter kubikzentimeter
das ist die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung einig müssen die
ganz regelmäßigen weltweit verteilt sein
weil zur zeit der entstehung das
universum eine homogene also
einheitliche wolke war
doch das ist nicht der fall es gibt
einen merkwürdigen kalten verkehr ist
zwar nur ein klein wenig kälter als 000
15 grad aber dass und die größe des
bereichs reicht um als seltsamer
anomalie zu gelten kann kein zufall sein
aber was verursacht dieses fällung
bisher dachten viele forscher und
forscherinnen das in den bereich vor dem
kalten fleck einfach eine große lehre
sei die diesen bereich kälter erscheinen
lasse
jetzt wurde das aber von einem
wissenschaftlerteam um rory mckenzie von
der université dunham in großbritannien
überprüft dabei kommt das ziel zu einer
verblüffenden erkenntnis es hat dazu die
rotverschiebung von rund 7000 galaxien
vor diesen bereich untersucht die
rufschädigung kommt er durch die
ausdehnung des weltalls zustande licht
bewegt sich ja immer mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit das gilt übrigens jedem
medium allerdings führte demnach wird es
immer an den atomen kunststoff
integriert und sieht dann weise aber
zwischen atomen hat es diese konstante
lichtgeschwindigkeit und durch die
winteraktion kommt zum beispiel zur
lichtbrechung bei einem prisma aber es
könnte in weltraum eben keine
rotverschiebung geben allerdings wähnt
sich eben der raum aus und so wird das
licht wie der schall bei einem weg
fahrenden auto langweiliger bei einem
auto wird der ton tiefer und das licht
wird eben gut sich das immer an die
raumzeit den eben diese feste größe der
höchstgeschwindigkeit nicht so würde
übrigens der wallstreet funktionieren
aber dazu später mehr
also anhand dieser verschiebung hat das
thema festgestellt die große lehre gibt
es nicht vor den greifen fleck ist alles
wie im übrigen weltall auch wenn das ist
auch das kosmologische prinzip das
weltall unabhängig von dem ort von wem
ich es aus beobachtet und unabhängig von
der richtung richtige homogen also
einheitlich also wat ass är anders an
dem kalten flex die wissenschaftler sind
jetzt auf eine verblüffende idee
gekommen die tat
die spannendste erklärung wäre der kalte
fleck durch eine kollision zwischen
unserem universum und einem anderen
verursacht wurde
die forscher also der zusammenstoß mit
einem paralleluniversum
die idee dahinter ist die existenz von
zahlreichen weiteren universen und wir
werden dann nur ein von vielen in einem
multi wertung die tat sollten weitere
noch detailliertere analysen der
kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung die
kollision zu prothese stützen
dann wäre der kalte fleck der erste
beleg für die existenz eines solchen
multiversum aber dieses thema habe ich
ja schon öfter hier berichtet james dazu
gibt's gleich es gibt noch eine weitere
these je allerdings mit dem
kosmologischen prinzip kollidiert ein
webfehler der in der phase der
rekombination entstanden
er wäre eben halt nur schwer mit dem
kosmologischen prinzip zusammenzubringen
schauen wir mal wie die
ursachenforschung mehr weiterkommt wenn
ihr also erfahren wollen ob wir mit
einem paralleluniversum zusammengestoßen
sind dann drückt mir hier ein abo auf
auge und vergesse nicht den auf die
glocke nur dann verpackt in zukunft kein
video mehr
hier gibt es die quelle zum thema
multiversum holografische universum und
so weiter meint wenn er darauf liegt
garantiere ich euch den track
schlechthin also bis dann bleib dran